[Musique]
le cube et au compost c'est vraiment un
outil agricole ça aide les producteurs à
transformer leurs propres déchets
organiques en engrais compost solide et
puis en engrais liquide
[Musique]
nous allons facilement atteindre les 40
tonnes à l'hectare par année
voilà parce que avec ce temps greg leca
nature et ceux dits bio c'est naturel
c'est approprié à notre sol en notre
terrain nous allons doubler tripler même
la production
[Musique]
on
nam et la bouse de vache que j'ai eus
mood encore on vient au mais la
lassitude de voir qu'elle est d'essayer
sec pour empêcher cet humain 17 minutes
cercle contient du cargo crime et de la
lui contient de la zone
[Musique]
l'ambition de l'onho c'est vraiment de
rendre à palau risation des déchets
organiques accessible à tout le monde
pas seulement en côte d'ivoire ni en
afrique le moins accessible à tout le
monde parce que c'est une matière
première à laquelle tout le monde a
accès
[Musique]
on
oh